estamos en la ciudad de Constantinopla
que es la principal ruta de entrada de
los abastecimientos para la ciudad de
bakmuth y muchas otras poblaciones en el
frente de esta provincia de donés aquí
hablando con algunos de los soldados
destinados a estas defensas en estas
poblaciones dicen que aquí ni siquiera
sienten preparativos para la
contraofensivo porque ellos viven
constantemente en una de las principales
batallas sino la principal que se Libra
en este país y hablando de esa
contraofensiva que esperan los
ucranianos empiecen los próximos días o
semanas a ellas se refirió ayer el
presidente
en una entrevista dada en conjunto a
televisiones nórdicas hablaba de la
importancia que significa para Ucrania
tener aviones este 16 que ha pedido a
Estados Unidos Pero ha dicho que ellos
no iban a devorar el comienzo de esta
contraofensiva a la espera de que
llegaran estos aviones de los cuales
Washington todavía
decide a entregar a este país lo que sí
se ha conocido por otras fuentes es que
Ucrania ya tienen su poder al menos 20
aviones 29 entre ellos 9 dados por
Polonia que ya estarían listos para
operar
tropas que comenzarán esta
contraofensiva la otan también ha dicho
que ya ha entregado todo lo que más 98%
de esta armamento que había prometido a
Ucrania para esta ofensiva Y es que
también decía el presidente volvió a
dormirse que ellos podían recibir esos
aviones en medio de esta contraofensiva
que tiene como objetivo final recuperar
esos territorios ocupados por luchas
incluido la Península de crimea y por
eso es tan importante tener esa Aviación